[Music]
ishana I am with I am so excited to talk
to you right now I'm a huge fan of your
work so it's amazing you're just killing
the directing and producing game but his
horror right now like where you want to
be or do you see yourself kind of
expanding the different areas definitely
I think uh I didn't purposefully do that
but horror just ended up I think being
the language that I feel most
comfortable in
um and so every kind of concept that I'm
interested in exploring I think just
ends up bending that way yeah and what I
love about your directing style is a lot
of the cinematography you have put into
it so when you're learning as you're
starting out are you still always
tweaking the craft learning more things
like is there a source you like to go to
or like a ritual yeah I mean absolutely
I think what I've learned in these last
couple years is that the moment that you
stop learning you become a more stagnant
artist
um so that's something I kind of
continually try to imbue into my craft
is the process of watching movies so
like any kind of recommendations that I
get from my friends I'll put down on a
list
um just trying to kind of consume as
much of the beautiful art there is to
consume so yeah and it is before you do
and I I think it's just like
really exciting to see your career grow
so for you though is there
as you keep doing it is there stuff that
you kind of want to make your stamp like
is there a certain like oh that's a Sean
is directing like do you feel that
subconsciously when you're directing at
all yeah I mean I think it's not
something that I am consciously thinking
of when I'm directing but uh my dad and
I do have really kind of different life
experiences and me being a young woman
as well just just makes the kind of
leans that I have different than his
even though at the base they might look
the same so I do think you can feel in
my episodes and particularly in the
later episodes my personality and them a
bit so yeah and that's what's cool it's
exciting to see before each episode like
okay what episode are you doing so how
do you guys go about that though like
are you like going oh I want that one
like how are you picking it from script
how does that go about absolutely I'm my
dad usually picks the episodes and kind
of fits them with whichever director he
feels sort of suit that suits those uh
the leans of the episode
um but I've been in a really lucky
position where I get to write and direct
some of them so for me as I'm writing
and one feels like me I'll be like I
want to do this episode let me do this
episode and kind of go to the producers
and ask
um so yeah it's kind of a specific thing
but each one is is crafted to to the
creators is there anything in particular
from such a great cast on this show you
learn from as a director just working
with actors of that caliber oh my God
it's just I mean it's really the most
beautiful experience they're all so
different and also incredibly talented
um and yeah I mean the the cinema
experience is very much about uh what
they can give and what we can give and
meeting those in the middle so you can
always I think enhance the performance
ends up way different than you thought
it would be because an actor is bringing
such depth to it so that's amazing great
answer everyone check out servant this
Friday Sean thanks for talking to me
talk to you Mr pleasure thank you